got kicked out of school wherever and
then I went to go get a job at Tesco I
remember like I had this interview and I
was walking down the stair my dad was
like where you going I was like I have a
job interview at Tesco he was no you are
not going there my son is not working
for brother well and good for you be
very careful cuz Allah
subhana Islam net is raising funds to
establish a mid and Community Center in
Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be a for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
you will in be reaping the reward click
the link and donate what you
can brothers and sisters and dear friend
so there's a video circulating I do not
know who this brother is he's called ish
something I think it's called ish it
might be sure ish I don't know okay so
this is a video where he is let's watch
for oursel let's watch for ourself he
says something about people who are
working in Tesco we'll give our little
two P piece in let's just watch inallah
and see what he had to say and the
lessons that we can learn even there was
a point where like I got got kicked out
of school whatever and then I went to go
get a job at Tesco I remember like I had
this interview and I was walking down
the stair my dad was like where you
going I was like I have a job interview
at Tesco he was know you are not going
there like he's like go back straight
upstairs my son is not working for like
n m we got standards in yeah he job
shaming you literally by the way no
offense to anyone that works in Tesco we
have to do this a lot because the
Internet it's his dad I mean bro guys
like you can say it a it but for me I'd
say ain't better bro yeah you I mean I
do
but he means like I mean like like let's
say this is your little if you think in
your head I want to work in Tesco
forever then I'm judging you yeah yeah
that's if you're doing it now and you
you know just get tring get some money
up yeah and trying to have something on
her side and taking it seriously yeah
that's what did you say about your wife
she working Tesco she did at one point
I'm so
sorry I feel bad now she this picking
the laptop like she's like the head
director of tesos right now it's okay
she anymore guys okay now this key
lessons to be learned from this number
one you need to understand these four
standards I come from a Jia in that Jia
I can remember very clearly uh working I
I'll be honest I was in the same thing
like working at Tesco oh my gosh if
people saw me in Tesco if I have to
drive there was these standards that
were given to me that was causing misery
to my life why because I had to be
somebody I had to make something I had
to be known for something many people
commit suicide many people feel like
absolute rubbish they feel like they are
inadequate they can't do anything they
got nothing to offer and I believe it's
irresponsible Behavior now did he mean
it maliciously we assume the best in the
brother maybe he didn't mean it l his
dad said that but again he has a second
comment where he's that n brother I just
want to talk to you again look I'm not
asking for anyone to send hate to him
it's I'm just doing this video as AIA
please anytime I talk about somebody I'm
not asking you to go and start sending
hate to him he's our brother in Islam we
just giving n to each other there is
nothing wrong in working in Tesco
nothing nothing wrong the prophet PP him
said the best of workers is a man who
works with his hands somebody who's
grafting who's working for his family
brothers and sisters yeah in Tesco why
is the limit and I want to be very clear
there are people who come just because
they have a certain lifestyle that their
fathers provided for them and or they
may have have made some well forever W
let me tell you something okay let me
tell you something there is ups and
downs in life there were times let me
tell you be honest with I was making a
lot of money and I lost everything these
things happen in life in Jah and in
Islam do not reach a peak and start
thinking you own the world don't Allah
will humiliate you whoever you are I'm
not talking to anyone specifically
whoever you are don't think and don't be
little Tesco for those people who are
working in Tesco in Audi in wherever
you're working may Allah bless and
preserve you have the intentions because
a Halal money that is earned with the
sweat that you're doing it is more
beloved to Allah subhana wa tala than an
individual Who's involved in riba
stealing doing this Etc be concerned the
problem we have with this and this
relates back to toed why all of our
problems relate back to toed why instead
of focusing about who thinks what about
you because you can even see the two uh
this I think the brother and sister the
brother there who was like oh my my wife
worked and you should have corrected him
why do we have this inferiority thing
when somebody makes a point and we're
like oh my gosh he's a guest who cares
what's wrong with working at Tesco bro
what's wrong with working at Tesco what
is wrong with it there is nothing wrong
with it so for all those people who work
in Tesco and I think at one moment in a
time when I first came to Islam I was
working at Tesco why to me I was like
you know what as long as I'm doing my da
alhamdulillah and I I I I was so sick
with chasing the world and the dun W I
was so happy working a 9 to5 and on the
weekends doing da with a it was just
like I was just loving it man as long as
you have peace from Allah subhana T you
can provide for your family now you can
have Ambitions and goals no problem you
don't need to work at Tesco for the rest
of your life and even if you did what is
wrong what is wrong why is the meter or
your yard stick oh you need to be you
know entrepreneur brother if everyone
was an entrepreneur the world would not
run so please let's be very careful and
correct people let's not have this
attitude where somebody a guest says
something and we have to go with the
floor no correct hold on a second
brother you know you're wrong here
there's nothing wrong with people
working in Tesco because this causes
mental issues people who are doubting
theel I'm inadequate I'm not doing
nothing in my life no you are doing
something for Allah subhana T you are
working hard for your family it's a
Halal income in obviously depends you
know what you're doing in Tesco because
you know again if you're working in the
aloh that's whole different that's you
can go to your local she for a fatwa but
what I'm saying is in a nutshell whever
you're working make it a priority that
you are serving Allah subhana tala it is
something that is aad it can be that you
are doing to make a Halal income if only
all of us were concerned about the like
the woman like a woman coming and saying
to you bring what I don't know who it
was from she said to her husband I don't
know if it's from the Sala said to her
husband make sure the income you bring
into this house is halal because I can
put up with poverty but I cannot put up
with a fire go Hell Fire that I can't
deal with but poverty I can deal with so
brother and sisters please let's be very
careful when we're seeing certain things
because this has a ripple effect on
individuals and their self-esteem and as
if they're not doing nothing good
alhamdulillah yeah Focus about pleasing
Allah subhana tala because the more you
care about what others think you will
never be happy they always have
different Yas stics for you you will
start working at T School they'll have a
problem you're working somewhere else
you become an entrepreneur they'll start
accusing you of this no one will ever be
happy with you and I've said it before
and I'll say it again from the moment
you're born is Allah from when you are
living is Allah from when you die it's
going to be Allah when you are enter the
grave it's going to be Allah when you
resurrected it's going to be Allah when
you are question it's going to be Allah
when you cross the it's going to be
Allah none of these people give a bloody
damn about you and when you die they
will probably back by you he worked at
Tesco listen my brothers and sisters
focus on pleasing Allah subhana wa tala
okay and for those who are entrepreneurs
and have that lifestyle brother well and
good for you be very careful cuz Allah
subhana tala W people who try to
belittle others and look down as others
wall I know situations of stories of
sisters in looking down on sisters who
don't wear the hijab and they fall into
situations worse than them because what
do they do they would oh this sister is
not wearing this don't they don't give
them Salam the same sisters off hijab
off jilbab off everything off they're in
clubs now nightclubs be very careful cuz
Allah subhana is very Swift in putting
you you in your place whoever you are
I'm not talking to the brother whoever
you are that's all I want to say in
there is absolutely nothing wrong with
working a 95 as long as Halal may Allah
bless and preserve you guys